I'm bitterly bitterly jealous of you for
many reasons but one of them is that you
were just made a spokesman for Guinness
beer I have wanted that gig my entire
life what better face to put on the
Guinness brand and this fat Irish head
right here more to pour Guinness into
exactly I know and is a good point I
find out that you got the gig I would
kill for that first of all
congratulations I thank you I thank you
what's involved here I yeah it's wait a
minute are you even Irish your name is
Offerman I am yeah my there was an
adoption in my family so my people are
Irish and Welsh and Scottish but it's
you're a mixture it sounds like there's
a mixed mixture of the British Isles
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm a hundred
percent higher all right I'm sorry but
again it eludes me why the gig went to
you and not to me yeah he's 100% Irish
with all the genetic limitations I mean
as a full-blooded Irishman then you must
be familiar with hardship yeah it's got
a point emotional distress and in off in
my defense Guinness has grown so that
they now have a us wing and they're
brewing Guinness in Baltimore out so I
have people in Maryland you know
[Music]
okay I see the kinetic robe I see the
Kinect picture I see the connection I
see why you got it and not me
are you very clear to me now I but I
couldn't agree more sincerely like it's
a lifelong thing you know even before I
knew I was gonna be an entertainment I
think as a kid Guinness has always had
really great ad campaign yes they have
yeah and you you I would think well I
don't know what I'm gonna do when I grow
up but I wouldn't mind being a
spokesperson for that Guinness Extra
Stout that looks like a pretty good gig
as a child you were saying this is it
true these were your first words as a
child not mama dada but I'd like to be a
slow prison for that Guinness Extra
Stout I'm uh I'm legally not allowed to
take this bit any further I don't want
to endanger the gig just if they're ever
looking for another guy I've got that
kind of leprechaun on speed bingo and so
no get it out there